is Jesus still a man in heaven with a
physical
body if you believe so raise your
hand if you don't think he has a
physical body and that he's still man in
heaven raise your
hand doesn't good no one raise your hand
if you you don't know what to believe
about that subject raise your
hand that's good that's fine this is the
place to learn if you don't know it no
no one comes out of their mother's womb
being a theologian or a scholar
according to the scriptures Jesus Christ
is still truly human with a physical
body albeit a glorified body that's
indestructible right now as we speak in
heaven in other words Christ is still a
man in heaven and he'll remain a man
forever and because he's a man he has a
physical body that's part of his human
nature a body that's now controlled by
the spirit it's a spiritual body meaning
under the Dominion of the spirit a body
that's indestructible Immortal and that
body is a prototype so to speak of the
bodies we will receive when Christ comes
to glorify us now let me confirm that
okay now let me show you that he's a man
in heaven with a glorified body let me
work backwards like I did yesterday
going to start from Revelation I'm going
to work backwards to demonstrate he's
still a man with a body so as a
Christian you're supposed to believe
Christ is fully God and fully human with
a glorified body and he'll never seize
being a man with a glorified body that's
something he willfully took on and
something he knew he would remain
forever he would remain forever a man
with a physical body something he
knew would be the case and the price he
had to pay and yet he paid it anyway
because that's how much he loves us
Revelation 22:16 sister read that aloud
for me what does it say Revelation 216
last chapter of the last book of I Jesus
has sent my angel to testify to you
these things in the churches I am the
root and The Offspring of David the
bright and Morning Star help me out here
how can Jesus still be an offspring of
David in
heaven you see what it says in
22:16 I am the root the foundation from
which David Springs but I'm also his
offspring how can he be the son The
Offspring The Descendant of David now
that Jesus is in heaven he's still a man
you got it lineage he's still what his
lineage you got it a lineage that we
have by virtue of being a man because as
God he has no lineage so in heaven he's
telling you I'm still human and as a
human I'm still connected to David he's
still my father I'm still his son but
I'm more than that I'm also his
creator because he's both God and man so
here Revelation 22:16 clearly he's human
he's a descendant of David but he's the
root of David the very Foundation of
David the very life source of David
because he's the God let me give you
other references let's go to 1 Timothy
chapter
2:5 1 Timothy 2:5 what does it say there
who is our mediator right now 1 Timothy
2:5 we have a mediator we have an
intercessor with God right now who is he
who's the one mediating right now with
God on our behalf the answer comes in 1
Timothy 2:5 for there is one God and one
mediator between God and Men the man
Christ Jesus the
who the man the
who the man Christ Jesus so he's still a
man in heaven yes
wow so should it surprise you that he
still has a God in heaven when he's
still a man in
heaven as long as Christ remains man he
will forever have a God over him the
only time that situation will end is
when he stops becoming a man will he
ever stop being a man never so he'll
never stop having the father as God over
him the price he willfully paid to
redeem us from the Wrath to come you see
his
love go to acts
17331 acts 17 30 to
31 read that for me sister if you don't
mind
okay truly these times of ignorance God
overlooked but now commands all men
everywhere to repent why why is he
commanding people to repent because he
has appointed a day on which he will
judge the world in righteousness by the
man a man huh so a man is coming to
judge the world sister a man is coming
to judge the world yes who is that man
whom he has ordained he has given
Assurance of this to All by raising him
from the dead so who is that man that's
coming to judge the world oh Jesus of
course the man that God raised that's
Jesus so he's still a man in heaven and
when he returns will he return as a
spirit or as a man as a man acts 2 we're
going to read from 29 to 32 but just to
explain the context Peter is going to
quote Psalm 16: 8-1 a Psalm written by
David about a thousand years earlier as
you go to Acts 2
29-32 in that Psalm David
says you will not abandon me to the
Grave nor will you let your Holy One see
corruption then Peter Builds on that
prophecy and he says to the Jews you
know hey David died and his grave is
with us till this day so that cannot be
a prophecy about David right he's been
dead for a thousand years he's seen
corruption he has decave he's in the
grave so was David mistaken or was he
talking about someone else so Peter
takes that particular Psalm to prove
that the resurrection of Christ was
prophesied in advance by the prophet
David with that said let's see what
Peter says about Jesus's body acts 2:
29-32 pay specific attention to verse
31 men and Brethren let me speak freely
to you of the patriarch David that he
both dead and buried and his tomb is
with us to this day therefore being a
prophet and knowing that God had sworn
with an oath to him that of the fruit of
his body according to the flesh he would
raise up the Christ to sit on his throne
he foreseeing this spoke concerning the
resurrection of the Christ that his soul
was not left in 8 nor his nor did his
flesh seek corruption sister help me out
here how did God prevent Jesus's flesh
from
corrupting by raising him from the dead
that's verse 32 so read the next verse
this Jesus God has raised up of which we
are all Witnesses so what did God raise
up on the third day Jesus Christ What
specifically flesh that's what the text
says what did God raise up on the third
day his flesh where is his flesh
now you understand glorified body you
got it it's a flesh body a physical body
that's indestructible Immortal cannot
die cannot wither cannot Decay flesh
body in heaven see I want to emphasize
that because you'll have some say it's a
spiritual body and assume if it's a
spiritual body cannot be a flesh body
that's a gross misunderstanding of
Paul's use of the term spiritual body a
spiritual body is a flesh body under the
Dominion of the Holy Spirit not under
the Dominion of sin that's right that's
what Paul means by a spiritual body
because you're going to hear some say oh
it's a spiritual body it's not physical
no that's not what Paul meant a
spiritual body is a flesh body that's no
longer under the power of sin it's now
under the power Dominion of the spirit
of God and as such that flesh body will
not Decay and there'll be no more sin
that it struggles with that's the body
we will have when Christ comes but as
far as Christ is concerned his flesh was
raised and made Incorruptible because
he's still a man with a flesh body the
two final references let's go to Luke
24 because we're reading acts and the
author of Luke wrote acts Luke 24 we're
going to pick it up at 36 to 43 Luke 24
36-43 the answer is in
39 Luke 24
36-43 got it go ahead okay now as they
said these things Jesus himself stood in
the midst of them and said to them peace
to you but they were terrified and
frightened and supposed they had seen a
spirit
and he said to them why are you troubled
and why do you
why and why do doubts arise in your
heart behold my hands and my feet that
it is I myself handle me and see for a
spirit does not have Flesh and Bones as
you see I have Jesus had what after the
resurrection touch me I am flesh and I
am bones proving that I am not a spirit
it's me come back to life on the third
day final reference to make my point
John 20 24-29 final reference so Jesus
has a flesh and Bone body a body of
Flesh that's Incorruptible Immortal
indestructible and he's still a man in
heaven that's what you're supposed to
believe on the basis of scriptures John
24-29 now Thomas called the twin one of
the 12 was not with them when Jesus came
the other other disciples therefore said
to him we have seen the Lord so he said
to them unless I see in his hands the
print of the nails and put my finger
into the print of the nails and put my
hand into his side I will not believe uh
Thomas's request presupposes what
exactly unless I do what see and touch
the wounds in his hands and his side
what is that
assuming resurrection that he has a body
not only a body it's that body that was
nailed to the cross with the wounds
still there meaning the marks of the
wounds so now Thomas may be mistaken
maybe he didn't know what he was talking
about but then Jesus shows up a week
later without physically being present
he knows what Thomas requested and a
week later he shows up and tells Thomas
what read it for me and after 8 Days his
disciples were again inside and Thomas
with them Jesus came the doors being
shut and stood in the midst and said
peace to you then he said to Thomas
reach your finger here and look look at
what touch what Jesus what are you
inviting him to look and touch my
physical body with the wounds intact
Thomas that's what you wanted to be
convinced that I'm alive here it is come
touch me how did Jesus know what Thomas
had said when Jesus wasn't physically
present that's his second nature you got
it although physically he's not present
as God he over sees and hears everything
so as God he heard Thomas so a week
later he shows up he makes Thomas wait
talk about torture he makes him wait for
a week you know maybe that's a way of
him disciplining him oh yeah is that it
I'm going to make you wait so the next
Sunday he shows up Thomas come here
touch and see the marks of the wounds in
my body stop doubting and be believing
and Thomas does the only thing that
anyone would do if confronted by the ren
Lord my Lord and my God and he worships
Jesus amen but you understand what this
passage impli lives not only does Jesus
have a physical body but the marks of
the wounds are intact in that body
something that he will continue to have
forever so that forever when you see
Jesus stretch out his hands you will see
the wounds as a reminder of his love for
you and the price he paid to save you
from the Wrath that come now you had
your hand raised brother yeah but Jesus
uh remaining the man in
flesh uh if one of the reasons possibly
so it's easier for us his flesh to
recognize him when we're there possibly
I mean that's Poss because because
that's what we are yeah but also because
God if he didn't become flesh could
appear in human form without actually
becoming human so it's possible that's
the reason but more than that if Jesus
Paid the price for our sin and the dead
at sin is death how do we know that his
payment was
accepted if he paid think about what I'm
ask Resurrection you got it if he paid
the debt for sin and the debt of sin is
death and God was satisfied with that
payment that means the curse of sin had
to be reversed what's the reversal of
the curse of sin you die because of sin
but if that curse is removed that means
you're not dead you're alive so the
resurrection is the
outcome of the fact that Christ paid the
dead for our sin which is a human death
and God was satisfied with that payment
so if he's satisfied with that payment
that means Jesus cannot remain dead
neither can you and I and that's to come
in the future so that's another reason
why he was raised to prove that God was
pleased with the payment he accepted it
on our behalf guaranteeing that you and
I will not remain dead in other words we
won't remain bod when he returns our
spirits will Unite with bodies glorified
indestructible immortal like his in fact
let me prove that to you Philippians
3:20-21 Philippians 32021 so without the
resurrection we would not have assurance
that God had accepted the payment so we'
remain in doubt and fear of death but
the resurrection destroys any fear of
death we may have and guarantees us that
you and I are headed to Glory praise His
holy name you'll find Philippians 3:20
to 21 saying that read that for me out
loud for our citizenship is in heaven
from which we also eagerly wait for the
Savior the Lord Jesus Christ who will
transform our lonely body that it may be
conformed to his glorious body our LLY
body will be like his glorious body see
Resurrection guarantees that brother so
praise the Lord but you see he's going
to transform our body of decaying our
body that's dying our body that's
corrupt to be like his glorious body so
that our bodies will no longer struggle
with sin our bodies will no longer age
our bodies will no longer Decay that's
the guarantee that Jesus's resurrection
gives us and how does he do it now how
does he do it according to the working
by which he is able even to subdue all
things to himself by the power that
enables him to subject the entire
creation to himself that's the power
that only God possesses